تنتشر جثث الجنود الروس القتلى
حول بلدة
بيسجيرودكيوسكي الذين قُتلوا بعيدًا عن المنزل
فيما اختار الكرملين تسميته
عملية عسكرية خاصة ، لكنها
حرب بأي اسم آخر ، وهي
مذكرة سيتم إلقاؤها على العديد من الروس
الآن بعد أن  -
بدأ التعبئة الجزئية المزعومة
ومن الذي قد يفي بنهاية مماثلة
هذه وثيقة بنكية وجدت على أحد
الجنود الجندي من سانت
بطرسبرغ وقد ولد في 30
سبتمبر 2001 وتوفي قبل ثلاثة أيام من
عيد ميلاده
المتفحم.  تنتشر بقايا الدروع الروسية
حول المدفعية
المنتهية ولايتها في المدينة وتطارد جيشًا كان
يعتبر في يوم من الأيام أحد أقوى الجيوش على
وجه الأرض ، وهو
جيش تخلى عن الدبابات
كثيرًا في حالة العمل ، حيث
يقوم ديميتري وطاقمه بالعبث
بإحدى هذه الدبابات حديثًا من ساحة المعركة.
يقول إنه يمكنني
تشغيلها الآن دون أي مشاكل ،
وتأكد من أن محركها الزئير ينبض بالحياة
عندما يهربون ، فهم لا يفقدون
الدبابات فحسب ، بل الذخيرة أيضًا ،
وفي المرحلة التالية ، يتم استخدام كل
هذا الدبابة مرة أخرى على استعداد تقريبًا للعودة إلى
العمل.  إلى
الشمال مباشرة من منطقة دونباس
التي يخطط الرئيس فلاديمير بوتين بعد الاستفتاء الوهمي
لضمها إلى روسيا ،
إلا أن القليل هنا لديهم ذكريات جميلة عن الحياة
تحت النفوذ الروسي ، حيث يقوم
ستانيسلاف بقطع الصفائح المعدنية لوضعها
على النوافذ المحطمة لمنزل أخته ،
وكان هناك نهب في الربيع.  تتذكر أنهم
كانوا يأخذون كل شيء
على الطريق
للعودة إلى ما فعلوه طوال
فترة الاحتلال الروسي ،
فقط جالسًا هنا ، يقول إنهم لم
يزعجونا ، لم
يجدوا أي شيء مزعج
للنازيين النازيين تقول إنهم يسألون دائمًا
أين
ترك النازيون الروس أو يرقدون أمواتًا فيه
حياة قذرة ضائعة أو لا شيء
بن ويتمان سي إن إن
شرق أوكرانيا